الخلاف بين قائد فاجنر ووزاره الدفاع
الروسيه جذوره قديمه وان فضحته الحرب في
اوكرانيا تحديدا لكن جذور هذا الصراع
الحقيقيه تعود لسوريا هذا ما خلص اليه
تقرير لصحيفه وصفرون الامريكيه وفي مقطع
فيديو كما نتذكر نشره زعيم فاجنر وقف
الرجل محاطا بجثث مقاتليه في مخمود
الاوكرانيه وراحه يكيل بالشتائم القاده
العسكريين واولهم وزير الدفاع سرقه
حينها اوحى للكثير من المراقبين بان هناك
صدعا اساسيا بين كل من فاجنر من جهه
والكرملين من جهه اخرى وتوقع ان تكون ايام
بريكوجين ربما باتت معدوده خصوصا وان موقف
الاخير لم يقف عند حد انتقاد القاده
العسكريين بل راحه يشيد ايضا بالقوات
الاوكرانيه ويحذر من ان روسيا غير مستعده
لمقاومه الاوكر بل ليس هذا فحسب بل قال
ايضا بانه كان يقاتل البيروقراطيه الروسيه
ايضا وفي تقريرها المطول تقول الصحيفه بان
لدى الروس او لدى الضباط الروس الكثير من
الاسباب لكراهيه فاقنر ومؤسس فاجنر تحديدا
كاتصاله المباشر مع بوتين وكذلك الرواتب
المرتفعه والثقافه الوحشيه للمجموعه لكن
كل هذه الخلافات ما هي الا كالجزء الظاهر
من جبل الثالث حيث تؤكد الصحيفه هنا بان
الصراع بدا في عام 2018 حين شنت دراغنون
هجوما على منطقه دير الزور السوريه تحديدا
حيث يوجد فيها كما هو معلوم حقول حقل
تحديدا حقول نفطيه هناك حيث توجد قوات
امريكيه وتضيف الصحيفه ايضا بما انه بمجرد
ما نفت الدفاع الروسيه العلاقه بفاجنر امر
البنتاغون الضرب وفي غضون ساعات قتل واصيب
المئات من مرتزقه هذه الحادثه وصفها مراسل
الحربي وكاله الانباء الروسيه بالخيانه
وقال في مذكراته لم نكن نعرف ان الطائره
الوحيده فوقنا كانت امريكيه وبان رجال
الدفاع الجوي كانوا جميعا يختبئون تحت
تنانير الفتيات
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات